yeah
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning totes honestly the most
reliable show and media outlet in the
world right there most reliable news
source and we're not even informed you
know the most informed warning show
without like really having any
information no it's like we're so
reliable trustworthy unbiased and we
actually know nothing
whereas compared to all these news
sources that think they know stuff but
then get it so wrong and I just have a
bone to pick today right councillor
snitch right merggle what did you wake
up to do today to pick a bone yeah and
your nose always oh yeah
guys I have not stopped laughing about
the thing on the plane yesterday like I
looked at that quote card we posted on
our Instagram like 500 times it made me
laugh all day no it made me like all
that you know what made me laugh this
morning been posted a meme about like
snitches throughout cartoon history no
of course he left you out of course of
course then I had a moment of like where
I zoomed out on my own life a moment of
perspective where I was like we call our
little sister snitch like it's her first
name like and I just realized it's her
first name and I just realized how weird
it was I had that moment once to myth
like names I was like wow I call my name
names my whole family calls things like
an out-of-body experience really weird
and it was enjoyable
so hey snitch okay like she has a snitch
cam she's counsellors snitch no I did
her name is snitch and it's now also
kind of counts I just had a moment where
I realize we're nowhere it is but I'm
don't worry it doesn't change any what
about the fact that you call me your
counselor that is really [ __ ] weird
honestly you're such a counselor like
you're the best counselor in the world
right so what am I supposed to call you
I don't know well it was feels like it's
been an eternity since yesterday's show
yeah so much yesterday was a busy day
not only did we do so cycled together oh
my god that was so painful like as if
yesterday wasn't hard enough right
claudia was just making news left and
right and I didn't even intend to like I
wish I had the power to make news when I
wanted like I would really like make
everyone me talking about my tour you
know like not not about all right well
you know what actually the tour got in
there because that's true it's all a
part of your story yeah I guess um we'll
get into that do you think it's time to
just get let me check my mmm I don't
know my goat do you know
the time because I'm pretty sure I'm not
positive I'm almost sure that it is time
- how do you say this
Oh deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast I
think this is like a truly a record for
the fastest we've dived into the morning
shows right I mean in the morning just
the vast five because it's only been
three minutes well it's because art is
imitating life and because you are the
news today so usually you talk about
your day but your day yesterday was the
news so our first story is from a news
source that bothered to do their
homework Entertainment Tonight oh yeah
Claudia Ashly details alleged Cuba
Gooding jr. assault as actor denies all
accusations I just cannot even believe
like how big of a story this became
because like what was the first time I
spoke about this story and had the
breath yeah I mean I've been talking
about this story with my friends for
years because it's like this crazy thing
that happened to me when I was younger
you still gonna have this story any time
Cuba Gooding jr. gets brought up on the
show yeah and so like everyone acting
like it's new news is so frustrating
because I mean the amount of like nasty
tweets dm's people literally even went
so far to message my personal facebook a
man named Hector Rios who works at FedEx
being like YouTube that to be Cuba's
type like I'm pretty sure of predators
don't have a type but like everyone
acting like this is new news and like
she's in it for money like I just I
can't say I can't stress this enough I
am NOT interested in keeping an
engineer's money so much so that if I
had I haven't heard from Cuba but if I
did and he was like I'll write you a
check to shut up like I would actually
turn it down I don't want his money I'm
not pressing charges I'm just sharing an
interesting factoid that might help
support the girl who's probably feeling
really alone because there's a video of
Cuba Gooding jr. grabbing her boob like
surfacing around the internet meeting
out okay you know what for and they say
she got a break because everyone's
yelling at me now so you know what it
was worth it totally I'll say like it's
just so funny you've been telling the
story on this show you know e News has
their snitches in here in the groups
watching the show stealing everything
that we say they definitely heard the
story before but it's not interesting
until someone else writes it up no and
you know what props to Radar Online you
know when I got a Google Alert that
radar online wrote me up I obviously had
like a pit in my stomach but they did it
in a way that was really like they
didn't take anything I said out of
context because I talk a lot on this
show and you could take something I said
and
in it and I just felt like they really
did their homework and didn't victim
blame and when I saw a news post sitting
next I was so disappointed because they
this were like running with the detail
of my butthole which is like first of
all so embarrassing and uncomfortable
for me but also like it's not the point
do you know anything they were just like
looking for clickbait acting like it was
you news like she's coming out now it's
like everyone is like oh she wants money
she's at thirst monster she's here for
15 minutes like do you think if I could
choose people to be talking about any
other one they're talking about my
butthole I don't want to be remembered
for this I wanna be remembered for a
great Netflix special hopefully so
stupidly people are so dumb and you know
what Sam and and I just like I just I'm
deeply upset with the news because not
only was there article just off in terms
of its tone in like the way I just
thought as a society we were like
believing women you know we weren't
gonna pay them in this picture where
it's like the way that this article
written was written it's like 50 years
ago it's a coming out of the woodwork
you know I know that this technically
isn't important but it is the choice of
photos oh [ __ ] oh game it's not even
the fact that it's it's old chin no and
it's the cosmopolitan I can't get past
the fact that like I'm a deeply shallow
person and I've worked really hard on my
body and I feel like I looked snatch now
and I would have loved if you know
everyone's talking about my butthole at
least they use a pretty picture of me
but no now pictures like that first of
all there's two problems with it because
one it's a side by side picture of me
looking like an absolute beast
next to Cuba Gooding jr. who is a
predator wearing glasses in a tuxedo
looking like a scholar at the librarian
he looks like the library looks like the
nerd who takes off his glasses and
everybody realizes he's handsome no
completely men when you put a pictures
like that it just opens up like
commentary to be so much more negative
about me because it's like who would
want to touch her big fat butt hole like
that's not me when people would say like
I have to share some of the notes
because I need to talk about the
logistics because I have worked in
editorial before so I imagine someone at
enews went to their Getty image database
yeah that photo of you is from when we
did a breath live but you're gonna have
to go a year and a half ago you know how
many new pictures there are of me that
you would have had to scroll further
down in the database right to to find an
ugly picture find the picture where you
looked worse yeah so there they
intentionally want to take a picture of
you it's not even about the chin say
like there are pictures of you from two
years ago where you're smiling and you
look like a nice girl but no you look
like
mean like accusatory like devil [ __ ] of
a woman yeah and he's act like fluence
is narrative like I'm not just being
shallow part of it is narrative part of
it is yes I'm shallow and I just wish
that they used a pretty picture of me
but that's not the point it's just like
a it's the overall message of like the
victim is evil like Junie a hundred
percent like consider myself a victim
liminal it's subliminal yeah it's like
josie and the pussycats
and then like I'm not gonna lie like
forever I was like one of those people
who was like I wish that you know victim
spoke out more about sexual assault but
like after yesterday like I can really
handle a lot I totally understand why
people don't talk about their
experiences I just I have to share so
many people went out of the right to
message me on my personal private
Facebook page like that is not a
platform there I have a public Twitter a
public facebook a public Instagram like
of all the places to go and find my
personal facebook Melissa Belton [ __ ]
why would a celebrity touch your big
face ass Thank You Melissa Oh Hector
Rios who is a Patchett package handler
at FedEx and a shift leader at Little
Caesars
stop lying on Cuba you fat [ __ ] you
[ __ ] lying piece of [ __ ] like to be
honest I totally understand why women
just shut up now like because who the
[ __ ] would want to go through this like
an I really can handle a lot and I can
only imagine the original girl who broke
this story like she this videos going
around of her like she's the must feel
so alone she's made her name is being
withheld she's she's an anonymous
accuser like I can I can handle it like
I really was feeling bad yesterday but
like I feel like I'm unique in that yeah
agree [ __ ] would want to go through this
for no justice no and you're not even
seeking just you I'm like I'm not I and
I just shared the story because I
thought it was an interesting fact to
substantiate the original person's claim
and I have to say the amount of messages
I got with like Carbon Copy experiences
from other people like then their friend
and I didn't get permission to share so
I won't but it's like grab my boob
grab my vagina made out with me without
my permission I walked out of the
bathroom at a restaurant I had no idea
Cuba Gooding jr. was in the restaurant
literally until I turned around because
someone's finger was literally touching
my ass and I turned around it's keep
getting jr. like I wasn't even talking
to him yeah also what's just so cop
first
the fact that he put out a statement
saying that he has no election like no
[ __ ] it was ten years ago you do this
every night when you go out like why
would you remember a random 16 year old
also acting as if I don't know who this
woman is like like when you were 16 you
were a celebrity and he targeted you
know and it's like I wasn't coming like
it's just so crazy how things get
misconstrued and I just know everything
I'm saying today it's gonna be taken
again because they were quoting from the
podcast which great press for the
podcast for sure but we're not scripted
so we don't think about what we're
saying so I just know everything I say
today could be taken one line out of
context so I'm just trying to be like
thoughtful so I apologize for speaking
like weirdly slow but it's just so wild
how one thing happens and another thing
is reported or like there are so many
people who like woke up today really
thinking that like I am out here trying
to slay the name of a good man trying to
get my 15 minutes of fame off of Cuba
Gooding jr. is back trying to get money
from him I can't say this louder or
clear enough I want no money
I want no fame for this you think I want
people talking about my butthole I don't
I really don't if you're gonna talk
about me please feel free to talk about
my morning show talk about the hard work
that I put into my comedy tour I'm
really you know itching for a Netflix
special like talk about that but like
can we like this is not what I want to
be remembered for per se it's it's not
what you'll be remembered for it's just
the flavor of the moment no but it's
like this is a slow news day you know
but people really like think that do you
know need me know for sure and that's he
so crazy our morons
totally I've never been more sure of
that people are morons and the media
news industry is discussing and we come
to this realization every once in a
while when we have a personal tie to the
news and then we see how it gets twisted
like how you say one thing and it's not
like they report and the other opposite
they just take one slice of it and blow
it up when it's just lacks context so it
really is disappointing and if you think
about it like grim to know and eNOS is a
source that we trust we cite them all
the time I'll probably have to continue
to cite them because like everyone's a
liar they were just the liar of the day
no totally but like I just I can't
stress this enough if humility jr. I'm
dead serious offered me 1 million
dollars to stop talking I wouldn't take
it what about you know like I really I
don't want it that's not what I'm
interested in and
interested in 15 minutes maybe I was
just sharing an interesting factoid
about my life because it is quite
pertinent to what's going on right now
right and I just I can't quantify the
amount of messages I got I've been
screenshotting them just because I think
it's so crazy and I'm not gonna share
them and I'm certainly not gonna share
without anyone's permission but I just
what they're sharing with me is what I
was sharing an interesting factoid you
should get permission to share them to a
side show on the toast Instagram I just
I can't explain how like very how little
I want to be involved in this drama but
I guess because I shared my story like
two years ago I inserted myself in it I
so don't want to be a part in the words
of Taylor Swift please exclude me from
this narrative one I had never asked to
be a part of since 2012
amen amen that's all on that yeah yep
sweet moving on because Gloria
Vanderbilt Andy Cohen his friend's mom
passed away at the age of 95 Wow I'm not
gonna lie I didn't really know like how
big of an icon she was until I watch
watch what happens live last night and
Andy Cohen like literally had tears in
his eyes I'm just like talking about her
and it was really moving really yeah
that's so sweet
Gloria Vanderbilt died Monday morning
according to her son CNN's Anderson
Cooper the fashion designer artist
socialite was 95 she died in her
Manhattan home with friends and family
at her side quote Gloria Vanderbilt was
an extraordinary woman who loved life
and lived it on her own terms Cooper
said in the statement she was a painter
a writer a designer but also a
remarkable mother wife and friend she
was 95 years old but asked anyone close
to her and they tell you she was the
youngest person they knew the coolest
and most modern yeah it's really sweet
it's sweet I mean I didn't know that
Anderson Cooper was at Vanderbilt I know
it's it's an interesting fact to weigh
and who's his dad that's Cooper because
I would rather be Anderson Vanderbilt
yeah but it it's good because it seems
as though when his name's Cooper that he
made it on his own and now we know and
we know he did probably did it yeah um
this is really all sweet living till 95
is such a blessing no totally when she
was on watch repins live she does not
look 95 and and he was like what are
your keys - you know aging gracefully
and she had just such a profound point
she was like just embrace it even though
she definitely like had some fillers but
stuff yeah you can embrace it and with
the Botox get you a girl who could do
both totally
I hope Anderson's okay anything like
really just thought about it and he's
like heart wasn't in last night's
episode of watch out and I look
one because I think like when Bravo
Lebanese are on especially from like a
low-level show like blow Jack like he
really doesn't care and to like his
heart was just elsewhere I understand
you know that's fair yeah we'll talk
about below deck yeah because I caught
up on it and blow deck is always the
show that like I never like keep up with
every week but like one Sunday will come
and I'll watch the entire season and
I'll be like damn I should really watch
this every week because it's such a good
show
yeah it's like when I'm super just
hanging around I'll watch it I've never
watched an entire season of below deck
anything oh my god I've seen episodes
remember a season and I can speak to the
squeegee girls yeah okay never actually
this season are no squeegee girls who do
the outside only screeching boys just a
smooth squeegee girls I know where is
this creature girl with the both sides
when you need her right and it's like
where's that presentation for women on
squeegees no okay and if you don't
understand our screechy girls with a
both sides reference please go back and
find the first episode where Jackie
watched below deck because it's so funny
it is
I think it's on our Instagram okay next
step last night where the MTV movie and
TV Awards which I really didn't intend
to watch but then I got caught up in a
Lifetime movie I did intend to watch you
but I caught it caught up in below-deck
things happen yeah I also I have a lot
of things to say about the MTV movie and
TV Awards one why doesn't she have more
than one award show it seems really
weird - why are they pre-recorded that
also seems really weird 3 I'm like
embarrassed to stay but like who is that
really bye I don't know counselor okay
look I get him good B's with Zachary
Quinto who's that
um I don't know I just like to see him
at Jemma all the time okay like that's
when when the host of the MTV movie and
TV Awards which is a mouthful and you I
should work on that because it's MTV
Movie TV
MTV is because it's music - whatever but
couldn't it just be the MTV Awards right
because there's MTV VMAs and but that's
the VMAs yes you know the MTV Awards
that also stand for movies and
television ha and the VMAs agreed
because this is a mouthful and maybe
that's why you had to pre-record it we
can get it out how you can I save money
like I don't understand yes I think it's
like a money saving thing I don't think
it's like a huge show for that show a
lot of shows have been like pre-recorded
now like the CM no that's the CMT that's
a cma fest um like I heard radio
your accordion are they yeah and I think
it's just a low-level thing yeah and
it's like if it's not a ratings you know
Bonanza then it's not worth the
investment in the live streaming
equipment which we know yes it is um so
I was gonna say I feel as though the MTV
music movie and TV Awards when the host
the host is really indicative of the
culture yeah and I'm just out who was
hosted in the past Adam Devine oh that
was good I feel like the rock did I
think rebel Wilson did oh yeah yeah
so really it's like someone who's
dominating movie and TV yes but also not
the most obvious choice always Tiffany
Haddish I think oh yes
so Zachary Levi snitch could we get a
Google search on him yeah he um was the
star of that movie Shazam that's a movie
yes not the show it's part of DC you
know what's okay you know because those
talking I watched the end of this award
show and he was in a new Superman like
type thing yeah super hero he's a super
hero called Shazam okay well that makes
sense as to why we don't know him we're
not big into like DC Martin but like you
know but I you brie Larson you know
right you know Batman you know the guy
Christopher but he's mad cute and I I
want to say he's Jewish
Zachary Levi I think I went to middle
school with him yeah that's like I think
we should know him it's good for the
community yeah good for a Jewish morale
maybe I'll catch Jewish Morales chili at
an all-time low these days
Tomas really need the sack really buy
like Reebok I think it's cuz like we are
the Jewish morale and our morale is at
an all-time low it's all separately
[Music]
Morales truly love okay you wanna hear
the winners sure here's what it's going
on in the world of young people you guys
I just wanna talk to your kids about it
I did watch a few awards one was that
Noah Centennial won best performance and
he like won the award like got on stage
sat down and then like was looking so
different like I can't tell I honestly
want to say I think he's on steroids
because like his neck looked like he
looks different yeah
and then also them and him and Lana
Condor won for Best Kiss Lana candor
Lana
okay best movie Avengers end game I
still have awaited spoilers I even if
someone told me this
I don't know who the people are don't
tell me I know you know I want to just
watch it to see if I would be like
interested okay do I have to watch all
the ones before it oh I don't know okay
best show Game of Thrones duh was anyone
even there to collect that's a good
question Oh actually I did see that
Stassi and Katie put up a picture with
grey worm so he was at the MTV Movie and
TV Awards and I think he might have been
the one to accept the award on the Game
of Thrones behalf because they don't
think like Kidd Harrington was
necessarily there but Melisandre is
boyfriend was their middle son died
Sunday did you see the toaster who's at
the Spice Girls concert and Miss Sunday
was behind her dancing oh my god so she
was just like in the stands if she was
to do so funny
yeah the Spice Girls like a reunion tour
is like taking over the UK yeah and I
just want to know like when are they
coming to America I don't know if it's
looking likely yeah actually I guess if
the touring the UK goes really well why
wouldn't they take it globe they did
Wembley Stadium is anyone opening for
them because it should be Little Mix ah
um it's it's it's jessalyn Oh - but I
would have thought it would have been
better brand alignment if Little Mix
I've actually just been thinking about
Little Mix a lot recently because when I
was doing this um partnership in Vegas
like some of the influencers we're
talking about Little Mix and I'm like oh
man you guys know Little Mix and then I
also follow them on Twitter and I just
really am thinking like how underrated
they are and especially in America
they're so underrated I was watching
their new music video bounce back
yesterday where I was having dinner and
it's just so good and there's something
they are the only group now that has
withstood like all the x-factor and you
know they're really friends they're
really out here doing it and I don't
know why they don't get more props I
didn't think you in the UK but like
fifth harmony couldn't hack it no not at
all
and like a shout out to my ex is like
you can't even compare the level of that
song to like a fifth harmony Bob no I
notice my girl
really yeah no that's my girl no but
it's no it's no shout-out to my ex and I
feel as though if they were bigger and
getting bigger you know they would get
even better songs their songs are pretty
good there and this gorgeous aesthetic
there me and video is so cool have you
watched I know I've been listen to this
and the dress that Jade's wearing with
the gloves yes that's how I showed you
yes who could tell me where that dress
is from their stylist is on fleek all
the girls are so stunning Leanne will
turn us in Pollock yes so
beautiful Jade stunning Harry I'm just
obsessed with Jessie Jessie like they're
so cool and they're all like real
British like stars cuz like Jessie was
engaged like another big British star
and it's like annoying Harry was engaged
to Zayn well of course but it's like my
best they're really like big in Britain
and now Perry's dating like a soccer
player football player which is just so
football or football yeah yeah yeah
which is so perked into the situation
it's like a UK dream no really you know
and I just feel as though as Americans
we're behind yeah no I'm not just do
better but I kind of feel like good and
special about the fact like I know about
Little Mix like nobody else does do you
know - yeah but they open for ariana
grande like it still isn't happening and
I meant to ask Margot did you end up
getting tickets for ariana grande I was
looking at tickets literally this
morning but they're like so sorry is it
tonight
yeah and tomorrow though interest on I
can't explain like how perplexed I feel
about the ariana grande concert like I
really like don't want to go well but if
you like I live to regret it
you won't live to regret it because I
went when it was the little it's
dangerous woman dangerous woman tour and
it was good it was good but it was very
like a lot of her songs are really just
like brassy tones and it's like a weird
vibe for like a stadium he's opening for
Ronnie and social house you don't know
if you should like some of them I
there's a good amount of sitting she's
so little and just like sits on the
stage and sings it's like it's not a
show that you have to see I can't
explain it and like her music could
sweetener compared to dangerous women
dangerous woman was like such a bell tea
album so if I if I ever dress about
coming to any of ariana grande I story
it would have been that I didn't go to
dangerous woman I don't think I will
live to regret breathy sweetener you
won't live to regret it but I think it
would be a nice night out for the
Steen's if we decided right but it is
also in Brooklyn oh nevermind gonna miss
g2o tonight uh yeah I think so
oh I saw her in Brooklyn she I think she
was at Barclays this weekend oh I didn't
know you could do both I thought you had
to only choose interest on counselors
honestly for a Steans right out at MSG I
might go right like what could be bad be
all dressed up like Ari it's a cute
night for the gal that's true think
about it
maybe tomorrow cuz like tonight I'm like
already I've already come to peace with
the fact like I'm not doing anything
tonight so tomorrow new tomorrow he's a
busy guy we got to get through the show
we have some business oh yeah
[Applause]
like no we'll talk about it tomorrow if
it goes well okay um it's nothing that
would like to affect you guys it's just
a it's a company around my step for the
toast but it's a big step for toast kind
yeah you know right okay let's get to it
it's the opposite it's a small toast
it's a small step for toast kind because
like doesn't affect anyone but us but
it's a big step for us I know it's a
small step for the toast but it's a big
step for Tina oh okay she's just like
the overall okay let's get to the
[ __ ] winners please Best Performance
in a movie Lady Gaga as Ali and the star
is born
of course best performance in a show
Elisabeth Moss The Handmaid's Tale no
one watches that here right you know why
don't you watch your hand means to know
okay best hero Robert Downey jr. as
Avengers end game um he beat Zachary
Levi I guess I'm a hero
that's really sad like even on his own
award show Best Villain Josh Brolin is
Thanos Wow I'm so [ __ ] out of it
that's kiss Noah Centennial ah no candor
reality royalty Love & Hip Hop Atlanta
what was better herb rules the reality
royalty that's really thinking women
they they never win and they push it so
hard when I think they're like really
upset that they never win I would be
they like got a party bus you know I
mean but they get to go to an award show
and it's like none of them have a 95 job
so this is like a fun night out for them
was a picture taken and Stassi looked
[ __ ] amazing Wow amazing yeah best
comedic performance Dan levy and chicks
Creek oh you know I saw that and I saw
his speech and he was like I know nobody
here like knows who I am but I'm really
excited about this happy Pride it was
really cute that's really cute he beat
Zachary Levi again Oh God
Best Breakthrough performance Noah
Centennial oh by the way and another
interesting fact to write about now is
Antonio is that every time his name was
announced over the loudspeaker for it's
Noah synteny Oh mm-hmm
that's just not gonna work for me no not
at all no it's Antonio best real-life
hero Ruth Bader Ginsburg and RBG most
frightened performance Sandra Bullock in
bird box okay Best Documentary surviving
our Kelly
ooh yeah that's a weirdo great call
really we'll have to watch actually I
feel as though these might have not been
like a noun son yeah no this is not like
the pre-roll best host Nick Cannon for
wild and out
cuz it's empty vain most amenable moment
the bachelor when calls and jumped the
fence wowwwww we won an award yeah
that's hilarious
did you think of his outfit and he was
wearing capris Gucci shoes Gucci jacket
gucci belt like gucci everything I said
I think I made it 1111 wish that came
true ok so those are big winners just
fun to keep up with what the kids are
doing
ya know to that really cemented for me
like how out of touch I am and you know
what I'm really ok with that
yeah I'm okay with it like I just joined
the lifetime movie club so when I really
retire he'll literally never see you
again I feel like every day say that I
feel like Tamra and that season of OC
where she's running away from the hotel
you'll never see it but yeah that was
weird scene yeah it was weird
uh wait I forgot to tell everyone before
we dived into the past five stories that
you need trouble-free makeup but take
about anymore and chose that the fast
track story so you need to know before
you take up goodbye w morning toes it's
brought to you by Sanford which is a
luxury fragrance subscription service
for perfumes and colognes also
pronounced collagenous a way for you to
discover new perfumes and colognes
without buying an entire bottle you can
choose from more than 450 designer
brands each month so there's product
tomforde Versace Dolce Gabanna Cartier
glossier Gucci Calvin Klein you choose
to perfume you want to try and they'll
send you a 30-day supply that's 120
sprays enough to supply more than four
times daily for a month not sure what
type of site you're looking for sort and
find your new fragrance by brand style
occassions season and more check out
user ratings and reviews on any
fragrance or take sanborns
true scent quiz to discover more
personalized scent recommendations and
with our exclusive offer just for our
listeners you can listen you can get 50%
off your first month at scent bird calm
/ toast that's only seven dollars and
fifty cents for your first fragrance
again that's scent bird calm / toast and
sign up for 50% off your first month
scen tird calm / toast for you to try
your first perfume or cologne for just
seven dollars and fifty cents say with
me guys Saigon smell amazing
that's one of my favorite um brand tags
yeah yeah we should do an official
ranking yeah number one is made the old
way it's old the new way yep um what's
number two there was another what were
we saying at in Florida sign on smell
amazing
made the Old Lace oh the new way o Noom
com what you have to lose okay
wait which a simpson denies romance with
Kris Jenner shuts down rumors he's Khloe
Kardashian's real dad he is an absolute
freak no character limit is going to
stop Oh Jay Simpson from getting his
point across they're retired NFL star
Jordan Twitter last week and rather than
fire off a series of tweets he's been
posting videos setting the record
straight on various topics he's a
blogger first of all the latest his
relationship with Kris Jenner and her
ex-husband Rob Kardashian hello Twitter
world this is yours truly he began a
two-minute video posted on Twitter my
life has always been involved in the
sports world in this and I suspect as
the week's go on that's pretty much what
we'll be talking about but once in a
while I'm going to go off topic and talk
about something else and this is one of
those times he should go on the sheds oh
my god we can't give murder as a
platform that's true but Ben called me
last night to tell me that today's
episode of the shit's is apparently
incredible he called me because like he
really takes it really personally and
like after the last two weeks he's like
you know everyone's really good and she
really feel like I wasn't like being so
funny I was being more like hosting it's
hard to you it's hard to be balanced to
like be a comedian and also a host so I
gave him a good pep talk before this one
him and his friend like a couple drinks
before and he called me after the
podcast recording last night and he goes
[ __ ] awesome I'm really happy for him
also he said that it's one of the
episodes that real real sports fans
would really appreciate so tell your
husbands brothers sisters wives
girlfriends dogs everyone like if
they're ever gonna listen to an episode
according to Ben this should be the one
to get into no become a [ __ ] sir
Schwitzer yeah I joined the ship it's
our Facebook group yes easiest way to
get to the jobs you know Bob Kardashian
was like a brother to me he was a great
guy he met and married Chris and they
really had a terrific time together when
they were together
unfortunately that ended but never and I
want to stress never in any way shape or
form have I had any interest in
Christian romantically sexually I never
got any indication that she had any
interest in me so all of these stories
are just bogus bad tasteless okay here's
the thing I know what a Simpson is
obviously like a liar mm-hmm but
something about him saying this like
makes me believe that there's really
nothing there because he's obviously
being a [ __ ] started this week yeah
there was ever a time for him to confirm
the rumors that him and Chris Fox or
that he might be Khloe's dad it would be
right now right or just to get hit like
this would be if you said anything you
know that might lead us to believe
otherwise like this would be huge
sorry you know he's probably gonna
become an influencer now cuz I don't
know like how many places they're gonna
hire you know what I saw his Twitter and
I followed it and then I was like no
it's like it's the same way how like I
don't believe in the sexualization of
Ted Bundy I don't believe in the
glorification of a murderer on Twitter
so I followed but I thought it was funny
at first like crazy murderer is on
Twitter again you know and then I was
like no it's not funny it's actually sup
yeah except the sexualization of Ted
Bundy is important to the story I know I
get it but I meant like the
sexualization of Zac Efron do you know
what I mean but it's important to the
story I don't care but it's important
it's part of the story I don't care so
you don't want the whole story no I
don't thank you for asking
okay well anyways what do you think
about this who do you think Khloe
Kardashian status I mean there was a big
part of me that really believed that it
was oj just cuz there are so many
theories she looks so different than the
rest of you sister DNA test and then
never shared the results on Keeping Up
she was like it's my business
but I think I I don't think first of all
I look like nothing like my sisters
they're 100% City all sales so I don't
know that that's enough to go off of
some people find pictures of each of
them where they look alike I mean you
can find you pictures of any people and
say they look alike
look you could really find a picture of
you and Jessica Chastain to be like
Jessica Chastain's check it out it's a
real mother no totally so and you can
find a picture of leg Ricki Lake and you
would say that she's my real mother
right or you could find a picture of
Miley Cyrus AB Squidward and say that
that's Mitch's real father it's true
I heard that Squidward is your real dad
yes and that's why you were so upset on
Father's Day yeah because like you were
confused he's the man who raised you but
you were also really mourning the loss
of like the secret you've been keeping
your whole life right right that's
Squidward and I just like felt since I
was spying above the ocean like he was
just like yeah like I could see his
house you can see bikini Bob yeah yeah
that's my battery it's a wild place
yeah like how drunk was the person who
thought of that so it was nice to be
like a Family Guy type of thing that's
why I was called bikini bottom but then
it just took on a life like a trusty
crab ill in bikini bottom yeah oh my god
why does he live in a pineapple like
what does that have to do with it maybe
the pineapples the dick no spongebob
squarepants abort absorbent and yellow
and porous is he
SpongeBob's fair he's nautical Montes is
something you wish I'm a little shook
that the Krusty Krab exists in bikini
bottom
that's [ __ ] vile yeah so that's an
interesting factoid I think so I'm gonna
go ahead and say that Chloe Kardashian
is not a loser then there was also the
theory about the hairstyle it Michael
something but I don't know I don't see
it me neither
okay didn't find a story you ready for
it sure because the Hunger Games prequel
is coming it said oh wait someone had a
suggestion about pineapples you know
pineapple is really good for vaginal
health I was thinking I'd have some
pineapple mm-hmm and where did Squidward
live in a stone right you're like in a
rock it looks like a rock he lived under
a rock because he was stupid that was
sorry yeah that I understood that one
didn't go over my head but what is weird
Margot where did your dad look like in
like Oh Legos like a house that's cute
look at it it kind of looks like a
clarinet okay you played the entire
Squidward's house house oh it was like
um erotic no but it looks like a
historic rock but okay it doesn't mean
anything it's an Easter Island head yeah
unquote interesting whatever okay
anyways I like growing up in that house
Margo it was lit you know me Squidward
his trick dad for sure for sure it's so
loving you wouldn't let me ever hang out
the neighbors but you know your
neighbors are wild veronik yeah Hunger
Games prequel set 64 years before the
first book is coming in 2020 so it will
be pre Katniss there will be no Jennifer
Lawrence there'll be no Jennifer
Lawrence The Hunger Games will return
next year as a prequel to the popular
books and movies authors Suzanne Collins
revealed Monday that she's writing a new
book that takes place 64 years before
the
the first book in the series and it's
set to release on May 19th so funny
bunny said there's a Hunger Games
prequel I thought it went movie I forgot
it was a book
well that's me a book but that maybe
I'll be a movie if it's successful which
is good I feel as though I've been the
superhero movie oh my god late and sandy
from SpongeBob her name is sandy cheeks
because her sandy cheeks are in bikini
bottom
yeah sorry I just someone shared that in
the comments and I thought it would be
interesting factoid that I thought I
should share it is there's definitely a
lot more Easter eggs um what was I
saying Oh superheroes like trilogies
there really isn't that like cult thing
happening right now that was like Hunger
Games
Twilight etc that's true we need a new
franchise we do based on books I guess
no Fifty Shades sort of game it was Game
of Thrones
it wasn't a TV show yeah but you know
what I'm saying where we get like a new
teen heartthrob no I really like want to
go to the movies at midnight like I
haven't done that and so long the last
movie I saw at midnight was the final
Breaking Dawn Part 2 Twilight I start
with Kristen at NYU like literally at
midnight and it was the best movie I
ever saw like that whole fighting scene
where it's like a dream in the dads mind
but like the dad died like I want to cry
yeah I mean that field of like Bela I
have to say I I love Twilight for so
many reasons like one I love Robert
Pattinson like but also like whoever did
the music for all the Twilight series
was a [ __ ] genius they introduced
Christina Perri into all of our lives
Green I used to listen to the og
soundtrack all the time it's just like
such beautiful it's actually great music
for a massage yeah it is Emily saw the
midnight premiere of The Fault in Our
Stars
oh yeah Mia martyrs just went to the
movies there were a bunch of crying
teenagers I mean my girl couldn't stop
laughing it was such a funny movie okay
the composer for the Twilight movies is
Carter Burwell he deserves a raise and
depression um and he also did Carol
three billboards outside a being
Missouri um no that ain't it says I
don't know if there's anything else
thinking but it's not the composer
it's the scorer no but that's it are you
sure yeah he does scores I mean he was
so good like Twilight all the
soundtracks are so [ __ ] premium and
they have new songs but they all like
tangle into each other it was just I
thought the Twilight series
as much as people joke about it being
like four twelve year olds it was really
a well done group of movies and I think
the next Saturday that I'm home I'm
gonna do a twilight marathon
I completely agree the new one that one
was weird yeah that one nolo where
babies yeah and they're at their
strongest do you guys watch Jessica
Jones yes that's why I called you last
night season three is on Netflix now oh
it is yeah and it's so good it's such an
interesting really good show I know
Krysten Ritter um [ __ ] like
superheroes I'm just not it's really
good what's what like I know a girl
named Jeff Jones it's just confusing me
no but it she's a great girl and it's a
great show Kristen with her like I do
Stan um like the scene where she spoiler
alert dies and Breaking Bad like it
really just like shook me like she was
being such a good actress like choking
on her own vomit from the heroine oh
never saw it
si never well I thought I should share
but the toasters that last week or maybe
two weeks ago I shared my favorite
episode of dr. Phil about the three
sisters who do heroin and I have to let
you guys know that in no shock one of
the sisters is a toaster she's sober she
did she went to a rehab facility met a
man there settled town had a baby and
it's like just living this happy
positive life em believe in California
um and she she said Alexis Neiers affair
no it had the same vibe when she comes
to New York she's gonna be gone the
toast so I just wanted I think she
wanted me to share with you guys like
she's doing really well and everything
and all of her sisters are doing super
well and she lets she's like lol member
that time I didn't I went on TV like
it's just like it's a it's a dark spot
you know in her in her past but it's
part of her story okay so those were the
past five stories um it's just an
exciting because you see more houses in
New York is moving to Thursdays really
annoying like it's [ __ ] out my
schedule my schedule yeah well actually
there's a night where we get a twofer
southern charm and Beverly Hills are
both on Tuesday and now house moving to
Thursday interests on I'd like to say
that it was like Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday
don't you say well I like when it's
Monday Tuesday Wednesday and then by the
end of the week I don't know what I
really appreciate the break because on
mondays like I'm still an weekend moan
and I'm not ready to dive into TV I have
to recap so I enjoyed not having to
watch anything not saying just like
accidentally catching up on below deck
matter which is [ __ ] premium Mila
there's like a huge like rumor going
around that started on reddit so it's
probably true that Mila who's the chef
below deck matt is actually a paid
actress because the show was really like
slacking and I totally see it but this
girl's an amazing actress and she
deserves an Oscar because she's [ __ ]
wild talking about Putin shutting down
the pride parades like she's out of
control
she's out of control I think she'll
probably get fired this season and then
it's like so crazy that they just have a
an extra chef on hand to take her spot
so that's why I feel you might be second
Stu yeah but she's not cutting it like
they didn't like her food but she's good
enough that she'd get something on the
plate but like they aren't like it she
can't last the hall but she can get them
through like a charter without Mila
before they can bring on a new chef like
she's coming like what would they have
done if they didn't have that cake
that's a good point you know really
that's an interesting she was like she's
filling the gaps until they can replace
the chef but there's no way meal makes
it through postseason no no on a
personal and professional level right
and then someone asks so both Hannah and
I get the second and third Stu's names
mixed up I think Anna oh they look so
familiar
Annelise a it's I don't know what oh my
god sees me I'm like worried about her
out um
they were in watch repens ID last night
and someone called in to ask Hannah like
why didn't you tell captain sandy about
what Mila said the night before about
homosexuality and Hannah was like well
because she she got fired because she's
better at her job like Captain Sandy's
really of the mindset it's like crystals
personal and business is business and
even I think captain Sandy's gay and
like I don't think she would have fired
me a lot just for that but she would
have fired her cuz she microwaved a
steak and couldn't make a cake and there
was baking powder chunks in the cake
right that's fair okay I should I didn't
watch the whole episode there's always
like so much chef drama on below Jackman
now I'm like going back and thinking
about all the chefs like okay Ben
he was probably my favorite he was the
best he's so rude to the girls like it's
so condescending cuz he's like higher
educated in London and like as Akal into
the cordon bleu and he was the best at
his job yeah and he like took it
seriously like Adam was such a piece of
[ __ ] dick and like getting to when
you're a chef you have to be above the
drama like at some level and he was like
so in the weeds with the three like the
the triangle I wasn't into him but then
you remember Leon no oh my god
Leon was such a [ __ ] dick I don't I
think they brought in bed to salvage the
rest of season cuz he literally he left
don't even think y'all fired and Rocky
was like riding her dying for him that
was the best season with Kate Rock and
Leon
below deck is such a good job yeah and I
I like the cast this season admitting to
me that Hannah was the only how ninja
Wow
but that Hannah was really the one that
keys I heard in JWoww I'm in the Bravo
for the toast group which is like when
they just do master threads for all the
shows and everyone watches live together
so I was watching live below deck last
night and I was talking about you and I
just like subconsciously spelled at JWA
dou W and I didn't think anything of it
until some guy was like it's Jay ayo ayo
but like I see her she short reference
note it's Shaima that's like the easiest
way to remember totally and when he was
trying to explain how his name was
pronounced last year to everyone he
should have just said like JWoww from
Jersey Shore that literally would have
made it so easy for me a hundred percent
he cried in last night's episode when he
was just talking about how he like
really can't stand Mia and her
homophobic remarks because he grew up in
Zimbabwe where homophone homosexuality
was illegal and he had like this auntie
jack or whatever was like he was their
mom's friend who was gay who like
couldn't talk about being gay and he
taught them like all had to do like
we're your clone on your back so people
smell you when you walk away and he
ended up committing suicide I'm like she
was crying and like I was literally
crying oh my god
I know like I didn't know that thing
about putting cologne on your back
that's really smart - it's not for
sunburn yeah for when you walk spray
your back smell amazing so when you walk
away people smell you I thought that was
really cute that is really heat okay I
have to finish you know like in this
house me Sandra and Joe and Hannah are
like really ending along the season and
Hannah was like a what happened to
Hannah's little boyfriend Connor yeah
when she was like dating a 12 year old
and they were chain-smoking every day
like that was just eyeballed chance I
can't leave I brought her back she's
really good cheeps to know some of them
like go after a smoke you know like but
they were like aggressively like smoke
like hey I'm like making like hate smoke
yeah like they wanted to like kill their
lungs because they were so mad at each
other
no it truly was is there anything else
we need to talk about I'm just no I'm I
don't want money from Cuba Gooding jr.
I'm not lying and if you don't believe
me I don't give a [ __ ] like cheerlead
grab a spoon
totally what a crazy trip this has been
I know like I'm really excited for the
new cycles change like I really don't
like you think I'm like a thirst monster
I'm like I love being in the headlines
but I actually really
like I woke up with a huge pit this
morning and I just want it to be over no
it's very anxiety inducing um I looked
for stories this morning and it's so far
very slow news day so I'm sorry this
always happens to us when we're in the
news it's like nothing happens for a few
days so we'll see you tomorrow right any
additional thoughts are you okay no I
you know I just because I don't know how
people get my phone number but I've been
adding text messages and like phone
calls from like producers would like to
go on TV I don't want to go and tell
email to be thinking I want to go on
Inside Edition and I want to go on any
of these [ __ ] TV shows but I just got
um a text and I don't understand it I
started keeping a genius story and
literally ten people send it to me
because the same thing happened to them
do you know the person oh wait who is
this okay I need to find out this text
message because do you want to do that
on the air no no like not at all oh okay
everyone have a great day you know where
to find us we will see you tomorrow
you